[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen wir
beginnen heute mit einem Satz der so
ganz unscheinbar in verquaastem prsprech
DAH herkommt aber der es in sich hat und
in Deutschlands Städten für
Alarmstimmung sorgen muss hier ist er
trotz erheblicher Bemühungen konnte die
erforderliche Liquidität für eine
außergerichtliche
Restrukturierung nicht in ausreichendem
Maß sichergestellt werden auf Deutsch
wir haben kein Geld mehr wir sind
zahlungsunfähig wir das ist nicht
irgendwer sondern die Signa Holding des
schillernden österreichischen
immobilienmoguls ren Benko der quasi aus
dem Nichts ein milliardenimperium
aufgebaut hatte und große Pläne auch für
Deutschlands Städte genauso wie die
millionenverpflichtung bei seinem
Warenhauskonzern Galeria Karstadt
Kaufhof steht hinter alldem jetzt ein
großes Fragezeichen Thomas münten
berichtet der Hamburger elbtauer eines
der Leuchtturmprojekte die die
signnergruppe in Deutschland gerade
umsetzen will seit Wochen ruht die
Baustelle nur Kontrollpersonal wacht den
Rohbau Zukunft völlig ungeklärt genauso
wie die Rettung der Galeria
karstadtkaufhof hier sollten im Januar
noch mal 200 Millionen Euro in die
Sanierung fließen wenn das Geld nicht
kommt sehen Wirtschaftsexperten schwarz
ja man muss immer ergänzen dass wir im
Augenblick die Weihnachtssaison haben da
wird eine Menge an Liquidität auch in
die Galeria reingespült aber nach
Weihnachten gehen nicht nur die
Weihnachtskerzen aus sondern auf die
Liquidität und dann wird es sehr düster
aussehen rund 42 000 Mitarbeiter hat die
signnergruppe weltweit wie viele
Arbeitsplätze mittelbar Unternehmen
hängen lässt sich nur schwer beziffern
Gründer Benko setzte auf große Nachfrage
Niedrigzinsen und hohe Immobilienwerte
doch dann stiegen die Zinsen die
Baukosten explodierten die Nachfrage
brach ein das Geschäftsmodell
kollabierte ren Benko denkt groß und
schillernd so erwarb er in New York das
chryslerbild für signner auf Kredit und
weil sich hochseriöse Unternehmen wie
auch die frühere Ruhrkohle heute eine
Stiftung an signner Beteiligten flossen
eben solche Kredite unklar ist seit
heute auch die Rolle von
karstadtsanierer Arn Geiwitz den hatte
Benko noch als Berater vorgestellt wenn
das Wiener Handelsgericht in jetzt als
Insolvenzverwalter einsetzen würde hätte
er die Macht auch Entscheidungen zu
treffen viele Galeria Mitarbeiter üben
sich heute in Zweckoptimismus Motto noch
eine Pleite wird
schon ich sag jetzt mal so wir haben
jetzt ja schon paar Insolvenzen hinter
uns ne und wir sind jetzt erstmal
entspannt wir haen der Dinge die da
kommen und jetzt haben wir erstmal das
Weihnachtsgeschäft vor uns darauf
konzentrieren wir uns und ja offen dass
auch eine Lösung gibt dass es auf Dauer
auch natürlich weitergeht in Wien baut
siner gerade am KDW Ager edelkaufhaus
Lamar hier herrsch heute normaler
Baubetrieb ob aber das Schlemmer und
flaniererlebt am Gänsemarkt in Hamburg
jemals Wirklichkeit wird ist heute
genauso unklar wie die Frage ob ein
Hamburger Investor wie vorgestern
angekündigt in den Weiterbau des
elbtowers
einsteigt hab vorhin schon kurz gesehen
geret Heinemann beschäftigt sich schon
länger mit dem Konzern und dessen
Eigentümer er ist
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Fachgebiet
Management und Handel an der Hochschule
niederrein Herr Professor guten Abend ja
schönen guten Abend her si diese
Gerüchte dass bei signa und Benko viele
es eher Schein als Sein sein könnte
gibt's ja eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten
war diese Insolvenz
absehbar die war aus meiner Sicht
absehbar spätestens als vor 6 Jahren
Wendelin Wedeking ehemaliger porschechef
ausgestiegen ist weil die Zahlen nicht
stimmen hätten eigentlich die
Alarmglocken schon luten müssen das
Konstrukt des ren René Benko besteht aus
rund 1000 Unterfirmen ein Investor sagt
dem Handelsblatt das sei eine Büchse der
pandor nach dem Motto bloß nicht öffnen
weil man Angst hat vor dem was man da
möglicherweise zu sehen bekommt lässt
sich das jetzt alles
entwirren es ist zumindestens unendlich
schwer wir haben es mit Verflechtung zu
tun auch sogenannten intercomany
Geschäften keiner weiß was da zu Tage
tritt und was unter Umständen auch die
Geschäfte und die Zahlen geschönt hat
was war denn das Geheimnis seines
Erfolgs Herr Benko hat verkaufen gelernt
bei der AWD er kann sicherlich sich gut
verkaufen und hat auch geschafft
wirklich Persönlichkeiten für sich zu
gewinnen das hat sol lange funktioniert
wie es Berch aufging aber seit es Berch
untergeht ist das Gegenteil der Fall in
Wien nennen sie so einen wie Benko
wunderwutzi sein Vermögen wurde mal auf
6 Milliarden Euro geschätzt wird er denn
jetzt
Arm ich weiß es nicht aber es ist zu
vermuten dass Herr Benko sich die Fründe
gesichert hat ob jetzt in Steuer Oasen
wo auch Verwaltung seiner
Tochtergesellschaften sitzen bei der
Durchgriffshaftung aufgrund der
beschränkten Haftung seiner
Gesellschaften dürfte bei ihm privat
offensichtlich nicht zu holen sein
insofern wird er Wohlhaben bleiben wir
müssen uns keine Sorgen um ihn machen
wenn jetzt das gesamte firmengebilde
zusammenbrechen sollte welche weiteren
Auswirkungen hat das denn hat das auf
Baufirmen etwa oder oder sogar auf die
Banken die ih Geld geliehen haben ja es
hat enorme Auswirkungen ich weiß jetzt
gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll also
Galeria Kaufhof sicherlich da werden wir
vielleicht gleich drüber sprechen
Baufirmen die noch offene Rechnung haben
die nicht bezahlt worden sind die
Baubranche insgesamt die weniger
kreditwürdig ist und vor allem die
Banken die auf erhebliche Teile ihrer
Kredite verzichten müssen sie haben es
gerade angesprochen Galleria
karstadtkaufhof die Warenhäuser die ja
auch die deutschen Städte immer geprägt
haben muss man vielleicht sagen äh wie
wird das denn jetzt weitergehen mit äh
mit dieser Insolvenz heute was steht da
den deutschen Fußgängerzonen ins Haus
äh es war bei der letzten Insolvenz
Bedingung dass die Sigma 200 Millionen
einschießt davon ist nur ein Bruchteil
geflossen mindestens 150 bis 180
Millionen sind nicht geflossen die
werden benötigt für die Umsetzung des
Insolvenzplans und das fil begalerier
kaufof gehe davon aus dass nach dem
Weihnachtsgeschäft es sehr düster
aussehen wird jetzt jetzt hat Benko für
diesen Warenhauskonzern auch 700
Millionen Euro an Staatshilfe bekommen
ist das Geld der Steuerzahler Weg es war
sogar kaum besichert es ist weg seit der
letzten Insolvenz 680 Millionen und man
muss immer ergänzen zweimal
Insolvenzgeld in der Größen Ordnung von
zusammen 320 Millionen das heißt rund
eine Milliarde ist in dieses Unternehmen
gesteckt worden und es bleibt im
Augenblick wohl kaum mehr als eine
Milliarde Umsatz
übrig alles was wir hier besprechen
schwer zu fassen ehrlich gesagt ähm
gucken wir ein bisschen auf das ganz
große Bild zum Schluss vielleicht noch
Herr Professor in Wien kann man ganze
Stadtviertel besichtigen die alle Herr
Benko gebaut hat warum hat ihm die
Politik auch in Deutschland immer wieder
ganze Straßenzüge anvertraut warum hängt
die Zukunft markanter Innenstadtlagen an
einem einzelnen Menschen also er hat
hervorragende Lobbyarbeit geleistet es
ist ja bekannt dass Herr Gusenbauer
ehemaliger Kanzler von Österreich 6
Millionen im Jahr bekommen hat um direkt
Einfluss zu nehmen auf die Entscheidung
für die Staatshilfe und das hat
offensichtlich funktioniert würden Sie
abschließend sagen das ganze ist ein
Skandal es ist mehr als ein Skandal ich
könnte jetzt dazu viel erzählen dazu
haben wir nicht die Zeit
das Kartenhaus bricht zusammen es ist in
der Tat ein Skandal Professor Gerret
Heinemann ganz herzlichen Dank für
ab aus
Düsseldorf und wir bleiben noch beim
Geld nicht nur der Immobilieninvestor
hat akute
Finanzierungsnöte auch die
Bundesregierung sucht händeringend nach
aber Milliarden seid ihr das höchste
deutsche Gericht die bisherigen Pläne
als verfassungswidrig um die Ohren
gehauen hat heute Abend gab es dazu
drängende Fragen an den Finanzminister
im ZDF aktuell sitzen die Spitzen der
Koalition zusammen auf der Suche nach
einem Plan B Daniel ponz
geht's euch gut fragt der Kanzler ihm ja
gehhe es auch
gut nur allzu viel Zeit hat er derzeit
nicht denn nach dem Willen vieler in der
Ampel soll der Haushalt 24 noch dieses
Jahr festgezurt werden ambitioniert
angesichts der nun klaffenden Lücke die
der Finanzminister am Abend in was nun
erstmals konkret
bezifferte für den Haushalt
2024 geh ich jetzt von ein Bedarf von
etwa 17 Milliarden Euro aus zum
Vergleich der Bundeshaushalt insgesamt
sind 450 Milliarden Euro ich sag das
deshalb weil gelegentlich jetzt von
Haushaltskrise gesprochen wird klar wir
haben eine
entscheidungskrise und zwar mit Blick
darauf wie man an allen gesteckten
Zielen festhalten könne trotz des
plötzlichen finanzlochs dass man daran
festhalten wolle gerade auch was die
geplanten Investitionen angeht betont am
Abend auch der Kanzler Erne mit
Zuversicht wir wollen uns dieser Aufgabe
stellen und werden das auch hinbekommen
dass wir genau diese
Zukunftsinvestitionen auch hinbekommen
werden bleibt die Frage wo gespart
werden soll sachdienliche Hinweise gab
es heute unter anderem vom Bund der
Steuerzahler die Personalkosten des
Bundes sei in 3 Jahren um 8 auf 43
Milliarden Euro gestiegen sparen müsse
der Bund daher als erstes bei sich
selbst das heißt natürlich erstmal ein
Einstellungsstopp wir haben die größte
Bundesverwaltung aller Zeiten fast
300.000 Angestellte und Beamte gerade
die Ampel hat ordentlich zugelangt wir
haben insbesondere hochdotierte Stellen
geschaffen über 1000 Stück in den
letzten Jahren wir müssen überprüfen ob
die Bundesbauten in ihrer Größe und i in
ihrer Dimension auch noch so
gerechtfertigt sind und natürlich
brauchen wir auch einen
sozialleistungscheck Abstriche beim
Bürgergeld etwa oder der
Kindergrundsicherung könnten sich auch
viele Liberale vorstellen im Gegensatz
zu SPD und Grünen die eher auf ein
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse auch
nächstes Jahr drängen und das Nein des
Finanzministers hierzu klingt heute
Abend nicht mehr ganz so kategorisch ich
bin noch nicht davon überzeugt dass die
Voraussetzungen für ein
notlagenbeschluss 2024 vorliegen würden
sie schließen es aber auch nicht aus ja
wir sind ja im Gespräch und ich finde
man man darf sich Argumente anhören aber
ich bin nicht davon überzeugt ob man
sich hier nun heute Abend beim
Koalitionsausschuss Kanzleramt
gegenseitig überzeugen kann am Ende ist
es wie in der Weihnachtsbäckerei man
muss sich auf ein Rezept einigen und das
eben erstmal
[Musik]
finden ja wer hat das Rezept versteckt
ein Plan B muss her und vor allem viel
Geld ein ganzes Land wartet viele sind
ja auch angewiesen auf konkrete Zusagen
des
staatesal beobachtet das Treffen im
schne von Berlin guten aben scharunterer
wie wahrscheinlich ist denn dass die
Koalition heute Abend auf ihrem
Spitzentreffen auch Antworten
findet ich fürchte das Land wird sich
noch ein wenig gedulden müssen denn wir
haben heute niemanden gefunden der
tatsächlich mit Ergebnissen aus dieser
Runde ähm rechnet nicht einmal die
Teilnehmer selber und ähm das heißt da
steht noch einiges bevor es liegen ja
einige Sachen auf dem Tisch das ganze
überrascht dass sie sich hier so viel
Zeit lassen weil äh wir ja gehört haben
der Zeitplan ist laut Kanzler Amt der
dass man bis zum Ende des Jahres fertig
werden möchte und äh wir wissen dass die
Verhandlungen hart werden das wissen
auch die
ampelpartner die Positionen liegen sehr
weit auseinander Christian Lindner hat
heute 17 Milliarden Lücke genannt darin
sind aber noch nicht eingerechnet die
längerfristigen Zukunftsinvestitionen an
denen die Ampel ja nach eigener Aussage
festhalten wird die große Frage woher
das Geld dafür dann kommen soll die
bleibt also weiter offen das heißt heute
Abend kann es eigentlich vor vor allem
darum gehen dass ein Auftakt gemacht
wird für die weiteren Gespräche und gut
wäre es wenn ein Fahrplan rauskommen
würde der etwas deutlicher macht wie die
Ampel in den kommenden Wochen vorgehen
möchte und wie sie tatsächlich zu einem
zügigen Ergebnis kommen will scher danke
dir für diese aktuelle Einschätzung live
aus Berlin jetzt weitere Nachrichten
hier bei uns im Überblick und den hast
du Hanna
lautverfassungsschutzpräsident
Haldenwang ist die Terrorgefahr in
Deutschland aktuell so hoch wie seit
langem nicht me grund dafür sei auch der
Krieg im Nahen Osten im jihadistischen
Spektrum gebe es Aufrufe zu Attentaten
und ein Andocken der Terrorgruppen
alkaida und is an den Nahostkonflikt
dies treffe nun auf hochemotionalisierte
Personen und könne zu Radikalisierung
von alleinhandelnden Tätern führen sagte
Haldenwang man arbeite mit Hochdruck
daran mögliche Anschlagspläne zu
durchkreuzen oder zu passt diese Meldung
wegen des Verdachts der Planung und
Vorbereitung eines terroristisch
motivierten Anschlags hat das
Amtsgericht Leverkusen Haftbefehl gegen
einen 15-Jährigen aus dem
rheinischbergischen Kreis erlassen
bereits gestern wurden seine Wohnräume
durchsucht laut NRW Innenminister re
äußerte der Jugendliche in einem Chat
sehr konkrete Pläne zu einem möglichen
Anschlag auf einen Weihnachtsmarkt in
diesem Zusammenhang wurde noch ein
weiterer Jugendlicher aus Brandenburg
festgenommen die 2020 beschlossene
Wahlrechtsreform ist verfassungskonform
die große Koalition hatte das Wahlrecht
geändert um Überhangmandate zu begrenzen
und den Bundestag zu verkleinern eine
Klage von Abgeordneten der FDP Grünen
und Linken scheiterte heute vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
inzwischen ist die Reform zwar überholt
der aktuelle Bundestag kam aber auf
ihrer Grundlage
zustande die telefonische
Krankschreibung könnte schon bald wieder
möglich sein und zwar Dauer Haft
zumindest bei leichten Erkältungen der
Gemeinsame Bundesausschuss von Ärzten
Krankenkassen und Kliniken will bereits
am 7 Dezember über die entsprechende
Regelung beraten bisher war dies erst
für Ende Januar geplant die telefonische
Krankschreibung war aufgrund der
coronapandemie durch eine Sonderregel
erlaubt die im April ausgelaufen
war Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat der
Führung Katas für ihre Vermittlungen
rund um die Freilassung von Geiseln aus
der Hand der Hamas gedankt einem Besuch
in dem Golfstaat Bart er den Emir von
Qatar zudem darum diese Bemühungen
fortzusetzen insbesondere auch mit Blick
auf die deutschen Staatsangehörigen
unter den Verschleppten er hoffe dass es
dazu in den nächsten Tagen gute
Nachrichten gäbe ein politischer Prozess
müsse auch mehr Perspektiven für die
Palästinenser schaffen sagt der
Bundespräsident heute auch noch in Qatar
ein Appell der wohl eher Richtung Israel
geht von wo er gerade kommt Perspektiven
das ist für die Menschen in Gaza ein
großes Wort sie sind aktuell mit dem
blanken Überleben beschäftigt große
Teile von nordgasa sind zerstört große
Teile der Bevölkerung dort sind geflohen
wir reden von 1,8 Millionen Menschen
laut UNO die selbst vor dem Krieg nur
ein Gebiet hatten nicht mal so groß wie
Köln und angesichts der alarmierenden
Zahlen von
Atemwegsinfektionen von Durchfall Krätze
und Lusen waren die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation heute es
könnten am Ende noch mehr Menschen an
einer Krankheit sterben als durch Bomben
lügwalport
berichtet die Großfamilie alkurt ist
erst gestern angekommen im Süden des
Gazastreifens unweit von chanunes Hassan
und seine Schwester ulfat mit Kindern
und den Großeltern Z Vertriebene aus
Gaza Stadt die eine traumatische Odyssee
hinter sich haben nachdem ihr Haus vor
zwei Wochen unter Beschuss
geriet age am Hafen von Gaza dann im
Schifer Krankenhaus dann wieder im
Zentrum wir hierher geflüchtet sind hier
gehe ich nicht mehr weg egal es ist
nirgendwo
sicher aus einem Fass haben sie sich
einen behelfsofen gebaut es kommen zwar
jetzt mehr Lebensmittel zu den Menschen
doch für die geschätzten 1,8 Millionen
Binnenflüchtlinge reicht das
nicht Wasser ist knapp sehr knapp Strom
gibt es keinen Gas nur ganz wenig wir
Ken was mit Feuerholz und auch das ist
teuer Israels Armee hat die Flüchtlinge
aufgefordt bei Wiederaufnahme der Kämpfe
hier im Viertel almawasi direkt an der
Küste Zuflucht zu suchen ein winziger 5
km langer Streifen doch sein Schutz und
Versorgung möglich heißt es wie
hunderttausende in kürzester Zeit hier
unterkommen sollen sagt die Armee nicht
deren Zusagen sagt Ahmed sind ohnehin
nur Lügen er will nach Sturm und Regen
die te
reparieren wir tun was wir können wir
versuchen das hier wetterfest zu machen
aber es reicht einfach nicht niemand
hilft wir sind verzweifelt mehr möchte
ich vor der Kamera nicht
sagen das Israel die Angriffe wieder
aufnehmen wird daran zweifelt Schadi
nicht er hofft auf mehr Hilfe aus dem
Ausland man könne tausende Flüchtlinge
unmöglich in Alma
zusamreiben das Gebiet ist jetzt schon
überfüllten
dorthin vertrieben werden das wird eine
Katastrophe es ist jetzt eine aber mir
macht das Angst noch dramatischer ist
die Situation in Gaza Stadt nach
unschätzungen sind 60% der Gebäude
zerstört oder beschädigt mehr als
100.000 Menschen harren noch im Norden
des Gebietes aus genaue Zahlen gibt es
nicht die Vereinten Nationen konnten
zwar während der Feuerpause in den
letzten Tagen Treibstoff und
Lebensmittel in den Norden bringen aber
es reicht nicht vielen bleibt nur die
Flucht in den Süden selbst wenn Ihre
Wohnung noch
steht es gibt da nichts mehr zu essen
die Menschen haben Angst sie kämpfen ums
Überleben sie versuchen sich irgendwie
in Sicherheit zu
bringen die Weltgesundheitsorganisation
warnt vor Epidemien Durchfall und
Atemwegsinfektionen vor allem bei
Kindern die Flüchtlinge hoffen dass aus
der Feuerpause ein Waffenstillstand wird
die Zeichen dafür stehen
schlecht unterdessen prüft die
israelische Armee eine Mitteilung der
Hamas nach der der kleine quir sein
Bruder und seine Mutter die als Geiseln
nach Gaza verschleppt wurden laut Hamas
bei einem israelischen Luftangriff
getötet worden sein die Familie hofft
nun dass diese Information vom
israelischen Militär Zitat hoffentlich
widerlegt werden wir hatten gestern hier
im heute journal über das Schicksal der
Familie berichtet Kir ist die jüngste
Geisel der Hamas er ist 10 Monate
alt wir müssen und wir werden die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen sagt der
usaußenminister ich habe da ein klares
Ja vernommen sagt sein Kollege aus der
Ukraine beide heute beim natoreffen in
Brüssel ein bisschen klingt das wie
Pfeifen im Walde denn allein die
Tatsache dass alle heute unermüdlich
darauf hinweisen müssen es gebe keine
Ermüdungserscheinungen bei der
Unterstützung für die Ukraine sagt
einiges die militärischen Fortschritte
sind rar an das Pad an der Front tödlich
wie Tim Kröger berichtet aus einer
umkämpften Industriestadt im Südosten
des
Landes eingepfercht im gepanzerten
Fahrzeug kommen sie aus afdka die
Polizeieinheit weiße Engel bringt die
Menschen aus der schwer umkämpften Stadt
heute sind es Swetlana und ihr Sohn Ivan
er wurde schon vor einem halben Jahr
durch Beschuss verletzt lange haben sie
durchgehalten jetzt aber wurde es zu
viel das war ein ständiges Angstgefühl
er sie treffen man wusste nicht ob man
am nächsten Tag noch am Leben
ist fast täglich fahren gen die Judin
undro die weißen Engel nachka dabei
wurden sie schon beschossen aber die
Panzerung hat sie beschützt sie retten
Menschen und bringen Hilfsgüter in die
Stadt wir liefern für unser städtisches
Krankenhaus sauberes Trinkwasser zum
Kochen außerdem Tee und Kaffee
wir liefern zudem gefüllte Gasbehälter
und wir haben Diesel für die Generatoren
dabei weiter dürfen wir nicht mitfahren
sie drehen selbst mit ihrer kleinen
Kamera das Ausmaß der Zerstörung in der
Stadt ist unfassbar der gefechtslm ist
allgegenwärtig ist schon lange umkämpft
seit Oktober aber versuchen tausende
russische Soldaten unter hohen Verlusten
die Stadt einzukesseln Putin braucht
Erfolge außerdem liegt aufdka direkt vor
den Toren der russisch kontrollierten
Großstadt donjzk die etwa 1300
verbliebenen Menschen schlafen in
Kellern und kämpfen um das
Überleben heute z.B gab es Beschuss
durch
gradraketen und das Haus das 110 Tonnen
schwer ist hat gewackelt als ob es eine
Schaukel wäre durch die heftige
Explosion wie bleiben wir am
Leben die weißen Engel haben das
Krankenhaus erreicht noch immer harren
hier Ärzte und Schwestern aus versorgen
die Patienten und bereiten sich auf den
Winter
vor wir sind bereit wir haben üfen und
Generatoren Brennholz und
Kohle rücke aus afdevka in der
Dunkelheit genadi und dmitro stammen
selbst aus der Stadt auch deswegen gehen
sie das Risiko jeden Tag aufs Neue
ein es ist wichtig für mich weil ich in
der Stadt mein ganzes Leben verbracht
habe und alle Leute persönlich kenne die
dort geblieben sind man muss ihnen
helfen ob und wie lange auf diefk nach
durchhält ist ungewiss und auch wann
genadi und mitro wieder dort leben
können sie hoffen auf die ukrainische
Armee zwei Kriege die die Welt
beschäftigen jetzt machen wir ein
Schnitt in dieser Sendung komm zurück
hier zu uns nach Deutschland mit einer
guten Nachricht Hanna ja und zwar mit
einer Meldung die sich im Portemonnaie
bemerkbar macht die Inflation ist im
November ein weiteres Mal gesunken auf
3,2% das zeigen vorläufige Zahlen des
Statistischen Bundesamts zudem sind die
Löhne im dritten Quartal seit langem mal
wieder stärker gestiegen als die Preise
Stephanie Barrett in Frankfurt was sind
die Gründe dafür ja drei Faktoren haben
Löhne und Gehälter stärker steigen
lassen allen voran die einmalige
Inflation ausgleichsprämie von bis zu
3000 € die Erhöhung der Mindestlöhne und
die Tariferhöhungen natürlich dieser Mix
sorgt dafür dass Arbeitnehmer mehr Geld
in der Tasche haben darf aber auch nicht
verschleiern welchen Kaufkraft und
Wohlstandsverlust Verbraucher in den
vergangenen 3 Jahren durch Inflation
verkraften mussten immerhin jetzt geht
die Inflation in die richtige Richtung
vor allem wenn man bedenkt von welchem
Niveau wir herkommen lag die Teuerung im
Oktober letzten Jahres noch bei fast 9%
sind wir jetzt im November bei 3,2%
angekommen für Entspannung sorgten
insbesondere die rückläufigen
Energiepreise die im Schnitt um 4inh%
sanken Heizöl Gas und Kraftstoffe
verbilligten sich deutlich
Fernwärmekunden dagegen sehen sich mit
steigenden Preisen konfrontiert und auch
für Lebensmittel mussten Verbraucher im
November erneut tiefer in die Tasche
greifen wenn auch der Preisdruck hier
etwas nachließ also selbst wenn sich die
Teuerung wieder abschwächt auf das
Niveau vor dem ukrainekrieg werden die
Preise nicht zurückkehren die
Finanzmärkte haben heute auf jeden Fall
positiv reagiert liegt das nur an der
sinkenden Inflation ja tatsächlich
hauptsächlich die Inflation bleibt
einfach dreh und Angelpunkt der
Geldpolitik die Notenbanken sehen es so
die Zinserhöhungen haben gewirkt und die
Inflation wieder Richtung 2% gebracht
damit lässt nicht nur der Preisdruck
nach auch die Notwendigkeit die Zinsen
weiter anzuheben lässt nach es entsteht
wieder Spielraum für Zinssenkungen und
die könnten der schrumpfenden Wirtschaft
wieder Dynamik verleihen das hat auch
den DAX heute hier wieder beflügelt und
ih deutlich über die Marke von 16 000
Punkten befördert vielen Dank stefhanie
für diese
Einschätzungen zu den Lottozahlen an
diesem Mittwoch die lauten 3 22 25 29 45
49 Superzahl 7 alle Angaben wie immer
ohne
Gewehr schon wieder ein Podestplatz für
die deutschen Biathletinnen bei beim
Weltcup im schwedischen Östersund haben
sie heute in der Staffel Rang 3 geholt
den Vortritt musste das deutsche
Quartett nur den Norwegerinnen und den
Schwedinnen
lassen hinter einer erfolgreichen
staffelleistung steckt ein ganzes Team
Schlussläuferin Franziska preus
profitiert zum einen von der guten
Vorarbeit ihrer Kolleginnen und einem
schwächeemoment der Schweden öberg die
in Führung liegend in die Strafrunde
muss so kommt es zu einem harten Kampf
auf der Schlussrunde preus gegen die
laufstarke Schwedin han ög ist halt han
ög das war mir schon bewusst dass sie da
läufis nur ein kürzeren zieh aktuell ja
ich habe schon gekämpft bis zum Schluss
aber ja sie war heute schon deutlich
stärker hart gekämpft haben auch die
Norwegerinnen mit Schlussläuferin Ingrid
landmarrevolt deutlich der Vorsprung auf
die zweit platzierten Schwedinnen das
deutsche Quart freut sich über
Rang sehen ist ja dass es uns mitnimmt
in Gegenden und Situationen die wir
sonst niemals wirklich kennenlernen
würden manchmal bringt es uns ganz
spezielle Einblicke die selbst im
Fernsehen selten zu sehen sind gleich
nach uns ein undercover Ermittler auf
der Spur von Schleuserbanden die mit
Kalaschnikows bewaffnet Flüchtlinge über
den Zaun von Serbien nach Ungarn und
anschließend nach Deutschland bringen
die Spur undercover bei der
schleusermafia jetzt gleich und zwar
hier im ZDF
ja und um 1 Uhr meldet sich dann hier
Christopher wermann mit unserem heute
journal Update und von uns allen auch
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras noch einen angenehmen Abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend selbst im Flachland
liegen zur Zeit bis cenm Schnee ganz
verbreitet in Deutschland und in den
Mittelgebirgen bis zu 40 cm an den Alpen
sogar bis zu 80 cm und jetzt kommt sogar
noch mal Schnee hinterher das liegt an
diesem Tief über der Biskaya das
schaufelt mildere und feuchte Luft daran
die schiebt sich über die Eiseskälte am
Boden und dann fällt nicht nur Schnee
sondern auch gefährlicher Glatteisregen
einige Schneeschauer gibt's auch mit dem
abziehenden tief hier über der Ostsee
das merken wir heute Nacht noch und zum
Ende der Nacht kann es dann im
Schwarzwald schon kräftig schneien sonst
ist es zum Teil auch mal klar das Bit
sich Nebel und es wird sehr frostig kalt
strengen Frost bis -10° erwarten wir in
schleswiig Holstein sonst sinken die
Werte auf 0 bis -8°. und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen um den
Gefrierpunkt ein kleines bisschen milder
wird es an Mosel mittelrein und oberrein
mit 3 oder 4° und dann wird eben aus dem
Schnee ganz häufig auch mal Regen
Glatteisregen das betrifft vor allen
Dingen den Süden badenwürttenbergs und
Bayerns wahrscheinlich erst ab den
Mittagsstunden in den Nachmittagsstunden
das warten wir noch mal ab freundlicher
sieht es aus hier von Berlin Brandenburg
bis zum niederrehein und an den Küsten
von Nord- und Ost gibt's auch noch
einige Schneeschauer der Wind ist meist
nur schwach er kommt so aus südlichen
Richtungen und in den nächsten Tagen
geht es winterlich weiter und auch mit
winterlichen Straßenverhältnissen also
es bleibt glatt auf Straßen und auf
Gehwegen bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
-5 und +3°. guten Abend